[Música]
y en directo a vamos hoy a Venezuela
porque la Corte Penal Internacional
autorizó a la fiscalía retomar su
investigación en contra del gobierno de
Nicolás maduro por presuntos crímenes de
lesa humanidad cometidos durante las
manifestaciones anti gubernamentales del
año 2017 la presidencia rechazó la
decisión y para ampliar toda esta
información nos acompaña nuestra
corresponsal Daniela Zambrano Daniela
muy buenas noches cuéntenos Qué
implicaciones tiene esta decisión de la
cpi
organizaciones no gubernamentales
defensoras de derechos humanos han
coincidido en que esto se trata de una
victoria contundente de las víctimas que
han denunciado que en Venezuela no hay
justicia y no se investigan estas
denuncias de crímenes de lesa humanidad
de violaciones a Derechos Humanos Qué
implican la práctica que se reanuda la
investigación por parte del fiscal de la
Corte Penal Internacional recordemos que
esta estaba suspendida a petición del
Estado venezolano a quien se le concedió
se le concedió un plazo para demostrar
que en Venezuela si se estaban
investigando estas denuncias del Estado
venezolano no logró demostrarlo así lo
considero la sala de cuestiones
preliminares de la cpi y Por ende se
ordena reanudar la investigación es
importante destacar que esto no implica
que ya haya personas señaladas y
acusadas formalmente ni tampoco víctimas
reconocidas como tal pero sí que avanza
la investigación en este sentido tras
las múltiples denuncias recibidas
también importante destacar que aquí no
se está juzgando al Estado venezolano
directamente si nos están Estableciendo
responsabilidades individuales en eso
han hecho mucho hincapié las
organizaciones no gubernamentales
defensoras de Derechos Humanos Porque
aquí se quiere juzgar directamente a las
personas que han cometido estos crímenes
de lesa humanidad Qué puede pasar que el
estado venezolano apele esta decisión
sin embargo consideran que aún así apele
esta decisión se continuaría con la
investigación Daniela Cuál ha sido hasta
el momento la reacción del gobierno de
Nicolás maduro al respecto
a través de un comunicado emitido por la
cancillería la administración de Nicolás
maduro rechazó esta decisión de la sala
de cuestiones preliminares de la Corte
Penal Internacional
recuerdan que desde
2018/2008 2018 que inició este proceso
Disculpe ellos han denunciado que se
trata de una estrategia para un cambio
de gobierno impulsado por Estados Unidos
no reconocen que en Venezuela se hayan
cometido crímenes de lesa humanidad bajo
la administración de Nicolás maduro y
anuncian que van a apelar esta decisión
Cuáles son los plazos el estado
venezolano tiene hasta el tres de Julio
para introducir un recurso de apelación
posteriormente debe formalizar sus
alegatos para esto tiene un plazo hasta
el 19 de julio y luego de esto la
fiscalía del tribunal Penal
Internacional tiene un plazo de veintiún
días para contestar la apelación del
Estado venezolano Pero según expertos
esto no paralizaría la investigación